SCP-682 versus SCP-3922. Who would win in this
matchup between the indestructible
reptile and the TV reality filter?
3922 is a small cylinder that, when placed
near a television, will alter the content of
any fictional material being played to
include a battalion of heavily armored
soldiers who proceed to arrest the characters
in the film and try them for their crimes.
The Foundation introduced 3922 to security footage
of 682. The tape was then altered into a 72-hour
military epic in which a coalition of soldiers,
all played by deceased actors, attempted to
terminate 682 over the course of the film. The
film ends with a final remaining soldier, played
by Patrick Swayze, alongside several gigantic
primates staring down 682 and preparing to duke
it out once and for all before… a TO BE CONTINUED
title card is displayed! Talk about a sequel hook.